ก็สวัสดีค่ะพี่อาร์ตี้สวัสดีครับน้อง
เรียมสวัสดีครับนักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะนัก
เรียน
อ้าววันนี้กลับมาเจอกันนะครับกลับมาเจอ
กับพี่อาร์ตี้กลับมาเจอกับน้องเตรียมนะ
ครับในช่องช่อง com  Free  and  slow ไทย
นะครับใครคะเท่ห์ครับผมวันนี้เรามาเจอกัน
วันนี้วันนี้วันอะไรครับวันนี้วันนี้วัน
เสาร์ค่ะหน้าวันนี้วันเสาร์โอเควันนี้วัน
เสาร์วันเสาร์ที่เท่าไหร่ครับวันนี้วัน
เสาร์ที่
19 เอาที่
19 ครับ 5 วันเสาร์ที่ 19 แค่วันเสาร์
ที่ 19
วันเสาร์ที่ 19 แล้วเดือนอะไรครับเดือน
นี้เดือนนี้เดือนอะไร
กุมภาพันธ์เดือน
กุมภาพันธ์ก็แค่เดือนนี้เดือนกุมภาพันธ์
แล้วอ่าปีนี้เมื่อปีคศอะไรครับ
ปีนี้คศ
2010  22 ค่ะพ.ศ 2020  2 นะครับแล้วปีพต
อะไรครับ
ข้อสองพันห้าร้อยหกสิบห้าค่ะอ่า
2565 นะครับปีนี้โอเคปีนี้ปีคศ 2000  22
หาแล้วปี
ปี่หน้าปีหน้าปีกศเท่าไหร่ครับปีหน้า
ข้อยศ.
2020  3 ข้อ
2023 นะครับอ่านแล้วพระเอกอีก
กี่ปีดีอีก 3 ปีอีก 3 ปีข้างหน้าเหมือน
กันนะจะเป็นปีคศอะไรครับอ่ะดูอีก 3 ปี 3
ปีในครับเป็นคศคศ
2025 เส้นไหมครับอ่ะโอเคโอเคอ่ะปีนี้
2,000 บาท 22 หน้าแล้วปีที่แล้วครับปี
ที่แล้ว
ปีที่แล้ว
ปีที่แล้วปีคศ
2000  21 ค่ะถ้าปีที่แล้วคศ 2010  21
เอา KSR ทรายครับอ่าๆแล้ววันนี้ครับวัน
นี้เรามาเจอกันกี่โมงคับวันนี้
กี่โมงนี้
9:00 น 15 นะค่ะอ่า 9 โมง 10 ขอ 5 นาที
อ่าเวลาพูดเวลาได้ยินคนไทยพูด9โมง9โมงแปล
ว่าเป็นตอนเช้าใช่ไหมหาค่าต่อช้อนชาเอา
9:00 นนะครับ
โอเค 9:15 นาทีตอนนี้
หาวันนี้วันนี้จะพานักเรียนไปไหนครับวัน
นี้
โรงเรียนจะพานักเรียนไปไหนอ่ะเมื่อวัน
ก่อนวันก่อนวันก่อนอาจจะเป็นเมื่อวาน
เมื่อวานซืนวันก่อนวันก่อนพานักเรียนไป
ซื้อมือถือมาแล้ว 5 วันนี้วันนี้จะพานัก
เรียนไปไหนพานักเรียนไปไหน
คานักเรียนไปที่นี่ค่ะพี่อาร์ตข้อที่นี่
อกที่นี่ที่ไหนครับที่ไหนแต่ที่นี่
นักเรียนเคยเห็นไหมคะ
อ่าอ่า
เพียรดีมองเห็นมีตื่นมิดอื่น
สูงๆเยอะแยะเลย 5 ที่นี่
แล้วก็เป็นพี่คิดว่าเป็นตอนกลางคืนด้วย
เป็นตอนกลางคืนด้วยที่นี่ใช่ไหมว่ามืด
แล้ว 15 มืดแล้วที่ไหนครับที่นี่ที่ไหน
พี่
กรุงเทพฯขอ
กรุงเทพฯเคอาร์พริตตี้รู้แล้วอะพี่
อาร์ตี้จำได้แหละจำได้และ
กรุงเทพฯเรียนรู้จักกรุงเทพฯไหมคะ
กรุงเทพฯใช่ครับกรุงเทพอยู่ในอยู่ใน
ประเทศไทยใช่ไหมอยู่ในประเทศไทยอ่ะ
กรุงเทพฯ
We  Are เมืองหลวง
เมืองหลวงของประเทศไทยใช่เฮาให้หน้า
ของอเมริกาคืออะไรเมืองหลวง
คิดว่าเมืองหลวงของอเมริกาเป็นอ่ะ
นิวยอร์กใช่มั้ยใช่มั้ยใช่
นิวยอโอเคเออมี
เมืองหลวงของประเทศอังกฤษอ่ะ
ชื่อเมืองอะไรครับ
ลันดาลอนดอนใช่มั้ยอ้ะลอนดอนเดี๋ยวค.คน
ไทยก็ได้เรียกลอนดอน
London  London  London โอเค new  york
อันนี้
กรุงเทพฯเทพอ้าโอเคที่กรุงเทพฯหลวงของ
ประเทศไทยเป็นเมืองหลวงของประเทศไทยครับ
อ่ะใช่ไหมครับไปเที่ยวกรุงเทพฯกันไปครับ
นี่ค่ะเห็นแบบนี้ที่กรุงเทพฯไหมอ๋อ
เห็นครับน่ะเขตกรุงเทพมีแบบนี้เยอะมีแบบ
นี้เยอะตลอดเวลาจะเฮ็ดหยังลดลดลดเยอะมากๆ
ใช่ครับรถบนถนนบนถนนมีรถเยอะหน้ารถติดรถ
ติดอ่ะไปไม่ได้ติดสิบไปไม่ได้อ้ะรถติดรถ
ติดเวลาเทียบตีจะออกจากบ้านที่ครับเทพ
ปราณี
ไป
เซ็นทรัลครับ
ไปสยามพารากอนอ่า
ข้าวบ้านที่จะตี้อยู่ใกล้ๆสยามพารากอนก็
จะเดินไปใช่ไหมคะอ่ะถ้าอยู่ใกล้ๆจะเดินไป
ดีกว่าอ่าเดินไปดีกว่า
หรือว่าเราจะ
ปั่นจักรยานในกรุงเทพฯได้ไหมคะอ่าปัดใน
กรุงเทพฯก็ขนาดปั่นปั่นจักรยานได้ครับแต่
ว่าต้องเป็นถนนที่มีมีช่องให้จักรยานปั่น
ด้ายได้ครับ
โละเที่ยวที่เคยเห็นนะนี้ไหมคะอ้าอันนี้
ใช่ไหมครับอันนี้เราเรียกรถเมล์ใช่ไหม
ครับรถเมล์อ้าในกรุงเทพมีรถเมล์หลายแบบมี
ถุงเทพมีรถเมล์หลายแบบใน
กรุงเทพฯที่เวลาที่เราอย่านั่งรถเมล์เรา
ก็จะต้องไปรอใช่ไหมคะใช่ครับไปรอไปรอรถ
คุณแม่ไปรอที่ไหนครับ
ไปรอที่ป้ายรถมาใช่ครับไปรอที่ป้ายป้ายรถ
เมล์นี้เรียกป้ายรถเมล์ป้ายรถเมล์ใช่นะ
เที่ยวที่รู้ได้ยังไงคะว่ารถเมล์คันไหนจะ
ผ่านมา
นี่ก็จะต้องดูดูที่ป้ายรถเมล์ป้ายรถ
เมล์ด้านล่างด้านล่างจะมีหมายแรกมีหมาย
เลขของรถเมล์อยู่หน้ามียี่สิบสี่มีอะไร
อีกครับมี 6
69 ใช่ไหมมี
92 หน้ามี
307 หรอ
107 เหรอครับ r  o  k
107 โอเคพอเพียงตีเห็นพี่ก็จะรู้ว่าจะ
รู้ว่ารถเมล์รถเมล์ใหม่เลข 4  24 วิ่งมา
วิ่งผ่านที่ป้ายรถเมล์ป้ายนิป้ายนิ
555 แต่ก็มีนี่มีสาย 69 วิ่งผ่านเขาหลาย
92 วิ่งผ่าน R เราเรียกว่าสายรถเมล์สาย
ที่ 24
5 สายที่
69 อ่า
สายที่ 92 อ่าแบบนี้เป็นชื่อชื่อของรถ
เมล์ชื่อสายรถเมล์เราก็จะมีตัวเลขสายอยู่
ตรงนี้ใช่ไหมคะอ่าใช่ครับจะติดอยู่บนรถ
เมล์ถ้าสาย 24 แบบนี้ใช่ไหมคะใช่ครับจะ
ติดอยู่
อะที่ด้านหน้าเดี๋ยวติวาดรูปรถเมล์ไม่มี
ประตูแล้วก็จะมีติดอยู่ตรงนี้
ตอนนี้มี 24 ตรงนี้มียี่ตี 4 แล้วก็ด้าน
หลังด้านหลังก็มียี่สิบสี่ติดอยู่
ทรายก็คือรถเมล์คันนี้เป็นรถเมล์สาย 24
ใช่ครับรถเมล์สาย 24
เตรียมค่าเรียนจะขึ้นรถเมล์สาย 24 เตรียม
รอที่ป้ายรถเมล์นี้ได้ได้พอได้ครับแต่รอ
ที่ป้ายรถเมล์ที่มีที่มีหมายเลข 24 อยู่
อ่ะรอได้รถเมล์หมายเลข 20 ก็จะมาแต่ถ้าไป
รอที่ป้ายอื่นที่ไม่มีไม่มีหมายเลข 24
นั่งรอรถเมล์สาย 24 ไม่ไปไม่ไปตรงนั้นอ่ะ
ทรายครับต้องมีไหมล่ะพี่อย่าขึ้นรถเมล์
สาย
555 รอที่ป้ายงี้ได้ไหมคะอ่ะไม่ได้ที่
สาย 5 ไม่ผ่านไม่มาที่ป้ายนี้ใช่หน้า
โอเคมันจะมี
ที่ป้ายรถเมล์ก็จะมีที่นั่งใช่ไหมคะใช่
ครับมีที่นั่งนั่งรอนั่งรอรถเมล์
แล้วก็มี
รถเมล์นี่ก็เป็นรถเมล์คนรถเมล์แล้วใช่
ครับบนรถเมล์ก็จะมีที่นั่งแบบนี้ให้อัน
นี้คือที่นั่งใจครับอ่ะ
แบบนี้จะเป็นรถเมล์ปรับอากาศใช่ครับเป็น
รถเมล์ปรับอากาศมีแอร์คนไทยเรียกว่ามี
แอร์ปรับอากาศคนไทยเรียกสั้นๆเรียกว่าแก
อะเป็นรถเมล์ปรับอากาศในอาปามีแอร์อันนี้
เข้าไปก็จะเย็นสบายใจน่าจะเย็นอาว่าต้อง
จ่ายต่างหากใช่ครับต้องจ่ายแพงกว่าแพง
กว่าแต่ถ้ารถเมล์ที่มีแค่มีแอร์แอร์แบบ
นี้ 5 แบบนี้ไม่มีแอร์แบบนี้ก็จะถูกกว่า
ถูกกว่าหน้าแบบนี้ก็อาจจะจ่ายเยอะกว่านี้
ก็จ่ายแค่ถูกกว่าหาถ้าไม่มีแอร์ไม่มีแอร์
แต่ถ้ามีแอร์ก็จะแพงกว่าใช่ครับเตรียม
นั่งรถเมล์ไม่มีแอร์ร้อนมาก
ใจครับเพราะว่าในประเทศไทยในประเทศไทย
ร้อนร้อนตลอดเวลาอ่ะฮ่าๆๆร้อนทั้งวัน
ตายเราก็นี่ไงที่บอกว่าอ๋ออ๋ออ่าใช่ครับ
หน้าเราสามารถปั่นจักรยานบนนี้ได้นี่บน
ถนนใจครับยี่ห้อ
นะคะเห็นแบบนี้ก็คือปั่นจักรยานใช่ๆครับ
งานสามารถปั่นจักรยานได้
เตรียมก็ชอบปั่นจักรยานต่ออ๋อ
มันก็ไปปั่นที่
บางกระเจ้าอ๋ออ๋อบางกระเจ้ามีที่ปั่น
จักรยานใช่ครับแล้วข้างทางข้างทางก็จะมี
ต้นไม้ต้นไม้เยอะหน้าให้คนหมาย
ตาย
นี่ค่ะบางกระเจ้าอ๋อ
บางกระเจ้า 10 แม่น้ำใช่ไหมมีแม่น้ำอยู่
รอบรอบบางกะเจ้า
รอบรอบ
ใช่บางกระเจ้าบางกระเจ้าอยู่ติดกับ
กรุงเทพฯ
แล้วบางกระเจ้าบางกระเจ้าเป็นเกาะ
ก็เป็นเกาะมีแม่น้ำแม่น้ำเจ้าพระยา
ไหลรอบรอบบางกระเจ้า
ห่วงชายมีแม่น้ำอันนี้เป็นแม่น้ำแม่น้ำ
แล้วจะข้ามไปบางกระเจ้าต้องนั่งเรือ
ต้องนั่งเรือใช่มั้ยอ้ะใช่ครับต้องนั่ง
เรือนั่งเรือเข้าไป
หรือหรือข้ามสะพาน
เนื้อหน้าขับรถข้ามสะพานได้แล้วก็นั่ง
เรือใช่ครับ
คือแล้วในกรุงเทพฯค่ะพี่อาร์ตี้ก็จะมีอัน
นี้
อ้าโอเคนอกจากมีรถเมล์นอกจากมีปั่น
จักรยานใช่ไหมเราก็มีรถไฟฟ้าอันนี้คนไทย
เรียกรถไฟฟ้าซมีรถไฟฟ้าใช่ขับรถไฟฟ้า
หรือบางทีถ้าเรียมถามพี่อาร์ตี้ว่า
ตีมามาที่นี่ยังไงคะอ่า
มาบีทีเอสเป็นชื่อภาษาอังกฤษอาจเป็นคือ
ภาษาอังกฤษของรถไฟฟ้านะครับชื่อ BTS
หน้ามี 2 ชื่อมี 2 ชื่อเป็นรถไฟฟ้าเหมือน
กันมี BTS
คนไทยก็จะเรียกสั้นๆเป็นตัวย่อ
BTS หรือ MRT
น้าอาไปฟ้า BTS  BTS จะอยู่บนดินแบบนี้
อีกอยู่บนบนถนนชายอยู่บนถนนอะ BBS อยู่บน
ถนน
ส่วน MRT
อาอยู่บนถนนนะครับ
อยู่ข้างบน
ส่วนเต็ม rt
MRT จะอยู่ใต้ดิน
ที่อยู่ใต้ดินทรายครับๆดีน่าอยู่ข้างล่าง
อันนี้เป็นถนนน่ะมีบ้านคน
บ้านคนอยู่วันนี้
MRT เราต้องลงลงบันไดเลื่อนแบบนี้ทรายลง
บันไดลงไปใต้ดินลงไปข้างใต้
อีก
BTS เราเรียกว่า
รถไฟฟ้าใช่มั้ยฮะอ้ารถไฟฟ้า BTS
สายครับอยู่ข้างบน
แล้วถ้าเกิดเป็น MRT อ้าเราก็เรียกรถไฟ
ฟ้ามากันอ่ารถไฟฟ้า MRT หรือเรียกมีรถไฟ
ฟ้าใต้ดิน
อาร์ไฟฟ้าใต้ดินใช่ครับอยู่ใต้ดินเรียก
mmr ทีเฉยๆได้เรียก MRT ก็ได้คนไทยก็จะ
เข้าใจเข้าใจว่าอ๋อคือรถสดรถไฟฟ้าใต้ดิน
เป็น MRT ใช้ขับ
ดีมากเราเราพูดถึงอะไรไปแล้วบ้างค่ะมีรถ
เมล์ r&i ครับมีปั่นจักรยานขยานใช้ครับ
แล้วก็มีรถไฟฟ้าหน้า BTS หรือ MRT หาหน้า
มีอะไรอีกครับที่กรุงเทพฯ
อ้านี้พี่คิดว่านี้นักเรียนนักเรียนรู้
จักรู้จักอันนี้แน่ๆๆ
ก็อ่าอันนี้เรียกว่าอะไรครับจะเรียกว่า
อะไรนักเรียนพิมพ์ Comment ให้หน่อยนี้
เรียกว่าอะไรเออ
ฮ่าๆๆเรียกว่าอะไรครับอันนี้เรียกว่ารถ
ตุ๊กตุ๊ก
รถตุ๊กตุ๊กใจครับอ่ะทำไมทำไมเรียกตุ๊กๆ
โรงเรียนรู้ไหมครับทำไมเรียกทุกๆฮ่าๆ
เพราะว่าเพราะว่าเวลาที่เราเราได้ยิน
เสียงได้ยินเสียงรถเนี่ยเราจะได้ยินเสียง
รถตุ๊กๆๆๆใจเป็นเสียงรถนะฮะหรอกคนไทยก็
เรียกรถตุ๊กตุ๊กไม่มีเสียงตุ๊กๆเวลาขับนะ
ฮ่าๆๆๆ
ทำไมคนคนไทยไม่เรียกรถตุ๊กๆๆ
แค่ 2 ครั้งออกรถตุ๊กๆต่อครั้งออก
ฮะโอเค
แล้วก็มีอะไรนะ
หน้ามีอะไรอีกครับ
ข้างบนเขียนว่าแท็กซี่
ข้างบนทำไมมีคำว่าแท็กซี่อ้างรถตุ๊กตุ๊ก
ก็เป็นรถใช้แค่ลดแฮปปี้เนส 1  5 เป็นรถ
แท็กซี่เหมือนกันเวลาเราขึ้นไปเราก็บอก
บอกคนขับรถตุ๊กๆว่าไปเอ่อไปสีลมไปสยามบอก
ได้ว่าจะไปไหนเขาก็ไปแล้วเราก็จ่ายเงิน
จ่ายเงินให้อ่าอันนี้ก็คือเป็นรถแท็กซี่
เหมือนกันแต่ว่าเราจะเรียกว่าตึกๆๆเรา
เรียกตามตามตามชนิดของรถ
ชายเราก็มี
รถอีกแบบหนึ่งเขียวเรียกว่าแอ๊คซี่อ่ะใช่
ครับมีรถอีกแบบหนึ่งที่อ่ะคะอันนี้จะเป็น
รถปกติเป็นรถยนต์ปกติมี 4 ล้อนะครับแบบ
นี้ก็เรียกรถแท็กซี่เหมือนกันถ้าเราพูด
ถ้าเราเรียกว่ารถแท็กซี่คนไทยคนไทยก็จะ
คิดถึงรถแท็กซี่เป็นรถยนต์ปกติ
[เพลง]
ใช่เป็นรถแท็กซี่ใช่ๆแบบนั้นเรียกแท็กซี่
แต่ถ้าเกิดเป็น
ลูกๆน่าจะเรียกตุ๊กๆให้ครับทุกๆก็เป็น
แท็กซี่เหมือนกันแต่ว่าอ่า
รถจะไม่เหมือนกันอ่ะเรารถตุ๊กตุ๊กก็ไม่มี
แอร์ไม่มีแอร์ตุ๊กไม่มีแอร์ก็จะร้อนหน่อย
ใช่ใช่ครับเนี่ย
ว้าว
เฮียตี้เคย
น้าๆๆอ้าวเรือใช่ไหมครับในกรุงเทพที่
กรุงเทพเราเดินทางด้วยเรือได้ด้วยเพราะ
ว่าในกรุงเทพฯจะมีแม่น้ำแม่น้ำเจ้าพระยา
นะครับอยู่ที่กรุงเทพฯเขาก็สามารถนั่ง
เรือเดินทางไปเดินทางมาได้อันนี้คือแม่
น้ำแม่น้ำใช่ครับแม่น้ำชื่ออะไรนะคะแม่
น้ำชื่อแม่น้ำเจ้าพระยา
แนะนำเจ้าพระยาไหลไหลไหลผ่านจังหวัด
กรุงเทพของเรา
หมอนหลายๆทรายครับ
เทียบพี่ก็เคยนั่งเรือไหมคะอ่ะเคยครับเคย
นั่งเรือในแม่น้ำเจ้าพระยา
นั่งเรือแม่น้ำเจ้าพระยาไหลผ่านไลน์ผ่าน
หลังบ้านพี่อาร์ตี้ด้วยนะไม่ใช่เอา
แม่น้ำเจ้าพระยาใหญ่มากอยู่ใกล้ๆใกล้ๆกับ
แม่น้ำเจ้าพระยาใช่ครับ
กูดีมาก
คิดว่าสวยนะอ้าใช่ครับสวย
แล้วอันนี้เขาเรียกว่าอะไรคะพี่อ่ะสิอัน
นี้เป็นที่ที่เราไปยืนไปยืนรอรออีกรอเรือ
รอเรือจะมาอ้าเราเรียกว่า
อ่าคนไทยมีภาษาไทยเรียกว่าโป๊ะอ้าหรือ
หรือเรียกว่าท่าเรือท่าเรือได้ที่เราไป
ยืนแล้วก็รอรอเรือรอเรือจะมาเพราะเรือมา
เราก็เดินขึ้นเรือไปเรายืนอยู่บนนี้บนท่า
เรือบนโต๊ะอันนี้คือเรือเหมือนเรือไหมอ่า
มาฮ่าๆๆฮ่าๆๆ
เวลามีเรือมาเราก็มายืนรอที่นี่ใช้ครับ
เรือก็คืออันนี้ค่ะเรือใช่นั้นเรือมาแล้ว
เรือมาแล้วที่เห็นโต๊ะก็คือตรงนี้ใช่ไหม
อ่ะอ้าใช่ครับอ่ะตรงที่ที่เรายืนหรอกยืน
รอเรือ
น้องง่วงโต๊ะ
แล้วมีอะไรอีกค่ะพี่อาร์ตี้ในกรุงเทพฯใน
กรุงเทพแล้วเดินทางด้วยอะไรได้อีกนะครับ
หน้าอันนี้
ที่กำลังลงเรือใช่ๆอันนี้ก็คือบนโต๊ะค่ะ
เรายืนตรงนี้อายุตรงนี้แล้วก็เดินก้าว
ขึ้นไปบนเรือสีแดงๆน่ะนะก้าวข้ามเข้าไปใน
เรือได้
ใช่ครับ
อันนี้คือเรือชายขับรถถ้าขอ
แล้วก็มี
เรือก็จะแล่น
ออกไปทรายใจครับ
ห่า
ชายครับด้านไปในน้ำ
หาแผ่นเอาพี่คิดว่าเร็วนะครับเร็วเร็วได้
งามว่าเรือแล่นเร็วเพราะว่าในน้ำในน้ำมี
เรือไม่เยอะสามารถด้านเร็วได้ใจครับ
อันนี้คือบนบนเรือท่านี้เรานั่งอยู่นั่ง
อยู่บนเรือนะครับมันก็จะมีคนนั่งอยู่
แล้วในกรุงเทพเราสามารถไปไปต่างจังหวัด
ได้ยังไงคะอย่าถ้าไปต่างจังหวัดอ่ะถ้าไป
ค่ะโชคผ่านใช่ไหมเราก็อาจจะต้องอ่านมีรถ
บัสใหม่หน้าเป็นรถบัสใช้งับเดินทางไป
จังหวัดต่างๆไปจังหวัดเชียงใหม่จังหวัด
ภูเก็ตไปจังหวัดต่างๆในประเทศไทยเราก็
ต้องนั่งรถบัสออกจากที่กรุงเทพไปนะครับ
หน้าวัดรถเมล์ไหมคะใช่ครับจะคล้ายๆรถเมล์
แต่ว่าจะวิ่งไปที่จังหวัดอื่นจะไม่ได้
วิ่งอยู่ในกรุงเทพฯนี่คือรถบัสใช่ครับ
อาจเที่ยวที่อยู่กรุงเทพฯใช่ไหมครับใช่
ครับอยู่นนทบุรีอยู่ติดกับกรุงเทพฯใส่ใส่
ก็เรียมอยู่มหาสารคาม
ถ้าจะไปถ้าเพื่อที่จะไปมหาสารคามนี่
ก็ต้องเป็นนั่งรถบัสรถบัสคันที่คันที่ไป
มหาสารคามอะที่กรุงเทพฯจะมีมีสถานีที่จอด
และสะบัดไปจังหวัดต่างๆในประเทศไทยเรียก
ตีกอล์ฟไป
เราเรียกรถบัตรก็ได้เรียกรถตัวได้ไหมคะ
อ้าเรียกรถทัวร์ก็ได้ได้ครับ
ได้เหมือนกันคนไทยเข้าใจรถบัสหรือรถทัวร์
แบบนี้ก็คือรถบัสก็ได้ไหว้ครับตัวก็ได้
แฟนเตี้ยใช้เวลาแป๊ปเดียว
ถ้าใช้เวลาแป๊ปเดียวนะครับถ้าแป๊บเดียว
เราก็ต้องนั่งเครื่องบินไป
ใช่นั่งเครื่องบินก็จะไปเร็วกว่าเพราะว่า
เครื่องบินบินเร็วกว่ารถบัสขับ
r&i เครื่องบินอ่ามีเครื่องบิน
ที่ประเทศไทยเราขึ้นเครื่องบินได้ที่ไหน
อ่าถ้าขึ้นเครื่องบินจะน่ากินอยู่ใน
ประเทศไทยบินอยู่ในประเทศไทยนะครับไม่ได้
ออกไปต่างประเทศอ่านในประเทศไทยเราเอ๊ยใน
กรุงเทพเราไปขึ้นที่สนามบินดอนเมืองสนาม
บินดอนเมืองบินอยู่ในประเทศในประเทศไทย
ดอนเมืองเรื่องเราก็จะขึ้นเครื่องบินไป
เที่ยงใหม่หน้าไปเชียงใหม่ได้ไปภูเก็ตได้
ไม่ใช่ครับเป็นสนามบินขายในใช่ครับสนาม
บินในประเทศ
แล้วที่กรุงเทพฯถ้าเครียดที่อยากไปเกาหลี
อ่ะถ้าอยากไปเกาหลีเกาหลีเป็นต่างประเทศ
อเมริกา
ญี่ปุ่นอ่ะอังกฤษเป็นต่างประเทศเราต้องไป
ที่สนามบินสุวรรณภูมิ
สนามบินผู้ชายสนามบินสุวรรณภูมิไปปาก
ประเทศครับ
ว้าวที่อามี
นี้หลายอย่างอ่ะใช่ครับมากๆๆครับโอเคอ้า
วันนี้เรารู้จักรู้จักการเดินทางใน
กรุงเทพฯไปหลายอย่างเลยมีอะไรบ้างครับ
วันนี้มีทั้งเดินใช่ไหมคะพี่อ่าเดินใกล้ๆ
ถ้าใกล้ๆเราก็เดินไปนะครับอ่านแล้วก็รถ
เมล์รถเมล์
เตรียมหามีรถเมล์แล้วก็มีปั่นจักรยานได้
ใช่ครับอ่ามีรถตุ๊กๆไหมรถตุ๊กๆนะโอเคอ้าว
ออกรถไฟฟ้าด้วยอะมีรถไฟฟ้า BTS  R  R  R
รถไฟฟ้า MRT เอง
part5 เคแล้วก็มีตุ๊กตุ๊กใช่มั้ยตุ๊ก
ตุ๊กใช่ครับอ่ามีตุ๊กตุ๊กๆก็เป็นรถ
แท็กซี่ชนิดนึง
แล้วก็เรือเมื่อตายแล้วก็สุดท้ายสุดท้าย
เป็นอะไรเป็นเครื่องบินใช่ไหมอ่านี่เรือ
อันนี้ก็คือเครื่องบินเครื่องบินอ๋อโอเค
ครับณวันนี้อ่านักเรียนก็ได้รู้จักนะการ
เดินทางอยู่ในกรุงเทพฯกันไปแล้วนะครับ
เดี๋ยวคราวหน้าคราวหน้าเราจะเรียนเกี่ยว
กับเรื่องอะไรเดี๋ยวมาพบกันในข่าวหน้านะ
ครับอ่ะอ๋อโอ้โหเดี๋ยวนะคราวหน้าเขานะ
เพี่ยนตีกับน้องเรียมเราจะคุยกันยากนิด
นึงนะยากนิดนึงนักเรียนต้องตั้งใจตั้งใจ
ฟังให้ดีดีนะครับ
เรียบคิดว่าโป้นักเรียนโอเคอ่าเรียนเก่ง
ขึ้นไปกับเกียติก็คิดว่านักเรียนเก่งขึ้น
แล้วแน่ๆแล้วเดี๋ยวคราวหน้าเรากลับมาคบ
กันครับณวันนี้เพื่อตีที่กับนักเรียนนะ
ครับลาไปก่อนแล้วครับ
ครับสวัสดีครับนักเรียนอ่ะสวัสดีครับน้อง
เรียมบ๊ายบาย
บ๊ายบาย
ม.ค